little man wants to be right the little
man is the people in your life who just
bring you down who are negative would
tell you all the reasons why something
is not going to work out the two common
traits one is little man always thinks
that he's right and two little man
always thinks small little man is just a
small thinker he just doesn't get it and
we all have the little man in our life
who tries to bring us down so one of
them wrote to me recently and we're
talking about an idea that I had a big
idea to help entrepreneurs any rights in
Duluth does he writes in if you zoom out
I'm right this is hilarious to me
because little man is when it's such a
small thinker he wouldn't know if a big
idea hit him right in the face he wakes
up and from day one he puts on his pants
he's thinking small that's what little
man does day in day out and here he is
telling me that if i zoom out and think
bigger that he's right this is the
problem with little man my goals alp a
billion entrepreneurs what's your goal
little man we all have these little man
in our lives pay them no mind little man
always has to be right even if he has no
idea what he's talking about he has an
opinion on everything and he always has
to be right and he's fully confident in
his opinion and that confidence can make
you doubt yourself ignore the little man
and the best way to argue with him is to
show him up proven you have an idea you
want something little man said that's
not possible use it as fuel to drive you
to create something amazing that's how
you shut up the little man believe in
yourself so those are you watching you
liked the video give it a thumbs up
below let me know you think leave a
comment you have a question put it below
make a video response and what else you
have you want to watch more videos like
this click the face you can subscribe
thank you so much and I'll see you soon
you